you know you say you are the worst tick
tock but
you are the only one of us who has
created a tick tock trend
because people have done all sorts of
iterations of this what lizzo sang that
song yeah
hey i'm keith i'm ned i'm zach
and i'm eugene and we're the try guys
and today we're with e.t we're going to
be reacting to some of the best
tick tocks about us so we've all had
tick-tock accounts for a little while
now
i wonder who do we think is the best and
worst among us
five four three two
[Music]
one
yes let's go tick-tock champion
it depends what criteria you're going
under right right yeah i mean i
probably now i probably post the most
but i still would say i'm the worst
yeah you have uh you are the most
frequent poster keith
so in terms of upkeep you're the best
you know it's interesting
eugene hates posting on there but when
he does
he puts a lot into it you know like he
only posts
cinematic tick tocks and they all hit
they're great yeah i like watching
people's tick tocks
um but all the other guys i would say i
would say
based on our video from last year ned
has proven that he's
the surprising tick tock daddy dads of
tick tock unite
uh i'm out here pulling down millions
upon millies of views
all the likes just let him roll in uh
it's an honor to be your queen this
evening
uh no i i had a couple of good ones yeah
some viral ones
you know one thing i've been trying to
do a little bit more lately is some
original audio
you know because i've i've mastered the
art of
the uh the the musical tic-tac but like
i'm trying to
trying to get this comedy career going
and so i posted a video of
me in a bridgerton outfit doing
bridgerton jokes
it's the corsets for me it's that my
only job is to marry wealthy for me
it's the and then my parents have to pay
a dowry for me
it's the all we do is drink tea for me
it's the
duke is here merrily monroe at marylee
monroe
did she use my audio to do a tick tock
let's check it out
it's the corsets for me it's that my
only job is to marry
wealthy for me it's the and then my
parents have to pay a dowry for me
it's the all we do is drink tea for me
it's the oh
the duke is here she did great she did
very good
i i she added a little like chest jiggle
when the duke was coming i like that
that's that's that's part of it all
right so
uh i'm gonna react to a tick tock right
now this is from
prentice osborne uh let's find out what
it is
oh yeah i know this song
yeah we're getting taco shells we're
getting ground beef
from the grocery store it's doing great
shredding the cheese straight in
although that looks like better quality
cheese
than you really should be using oh and
the cat's there as well
wow wow she's sitting with all the cats
okay that's great that was the world
famous song by me white people taco
night which is a very funny origin it's
just i made that song up on one of our
tripod episodes our podcast and the
episode opens with me just singing that
a fan uploaded that original audio to
tiktok
and it kind of blew up on its own uh so
then i was like well i can't i'm not
even accredited to this right now so i
wrote a whole song
around that uh opening sort of chorus
and uh i built a whole song out and this
one actually is using the whole
song but it's very cool because i've
actually had more success on tick tock
from a fan posting me than i have myself
which feels very tick-tock you know you
say you are the worst
tick-tock but you are the only one of us
who has created
a tick tock trend because people have
done all sorts of iterations of this
what lizzo sang that song yeah lizzo
did green chili enchilada night to this
uh theme and lots of people have done it
lots of people have also
you know done different uh types of
foods
green chili enchiladas night
you got garlic and green chilies from
new mexico and you put in a non-dairy
creamy soup
then you season that the joke is just
that like growing up i think
every uh every family in america white
or not
uh had this same experience of this
grocery store taco night and you know
what it's slacks
i do it now i this song actually made me
start eating that meal more frequently
and the meal is delicious yeah and and
there's a magic power
in taco night at home where like i think
normally you can only eat like three or
four tacos as a person
but when you have taco night at home i
can eat nine
i think princess tacos are probably
pretty good also i gotta say i love the
fact that she ate them on the floor with
her cats
so i don't know if her food is better
but her
setup for dining is far superior
i know i look like zach from the try
guys
i get it i'm a white dude with brown
hair
i look like all of them check it out
he's wearing green he's jacksepticeye
top of the morning to you laddie is that
what you
wanted this is the point that you've
gotten me to
so i know this one well this is from
absolute bean boy
shout out to peter uh it's him screaming
shaking the camera
saying uh i know i look like zach from
the try guys
i get it i'm a white dude with brown
hair i look like all of them
uh so port peter we actually we follow
each other now on tick tock and he'll
dm me other tick tocks that he thinks
i'm going to like so i don't know if he
means to or not but we've got a little
blooming friendship
oh poor peter on every single tick tock
he makes
people will comment hey kind of looks
like corn date hey collins like corndie
and pork i get it look he's just out
here trying to make comedy videos he
doesn't need to know that he looks like
me
but i actually uh i do edited this uh
and and it did quite well it got 1.3
million views
so thanks for that was like my first
tick tock in a while
uh and funny my fiance keeps telling me
you can on tic tac just rely on people
knowing you and i'm like well
i did that and it was the most
successful thing i've done in months
so i think that is the key to great
content for me
all right so this is a tick tock duet
done by
at gummy bee and it is i believe
duetting
one of the first tick tocks i posted
which was for the try guys video when we
started tick tock
where i just did a surprise jump split
in the middle of a crowded room
that was everything oh his performance
was 13 out of 10. that was
the the flying papers the the bounce
once he was in the drop split it was moi
perfection could not have honestly i
think he did it better than me
because i broke my phone doing this he
did
yeah i mean yeah he did this like turn
around
jump shot and then like eyes to the sky
and then i love the bounce at the end
yeah the try guys are
going on tour baby who wants some fried
chicken
can we prove ourselves as valid content
creators who are out there making
real change what we do not just making
content because we can make money from
it
uh so our new movie behind the try a try
guys documentary
i think the coolest part of making it
was frankly
learning more about each other we've
been doing
this for for six years and we thought
that we knew all there was to know
but it's a really true intimate uh
portrait of ourselves as a group but
also as individuals
and yeah i found myself surprised in
understanding my friends in ways that i
never had
i also think the movie is just
ultimately a love letter to
our fans and and what they mean to us
and it's been really special to share it
with them and to communicate to them
the impact they've had on our lives well
i hope that by watching it they'll get
an inside look at what it means to be a
try guy
what it's like to be part of a group
that's intensely collaborative and
passionate
and how do our various individual
struggles pursuits hopes dreams goals
uh combined with our our group goals and
what
we want to do with our brand and what
what it's like to go on a 20 city live
tour
and live on a tour bus for a month you
know when we're in
close company with each other do we
make it or do we break up that's that's
kind of one of the tensions of the film
i think it's important
for you know young kids out there
especially who follow people
whether they're celebrities or
influencers or youtubers to know that
everyone's human
and everyone is trying to cultivate this
like very particular image
so i think it's really important for
everyone to always like loosen that
pressure on themselves
and not feel like they have to be like
what they see in social media what they
see
on youtube um even the people that you
think have it all together don't
so i think that's a really good lesson
to take away from something like our
documentary
even if you don't know us it's a pretty
interesting look at how a
massively popular online group
functions behind the try a try guys
documentary is now available
streaming everywhere or you can go to
trygus.com movie
thanks